if you had to choose a contestant with  someone else's team to win who would it  be a lie you've lived you've left me no  choice here to but to say win because  it's my goal in life to beat Adam or see  him or to see somebody beat him so I'm  gonna pick Jeffery that's who I would  pick to win I also would have to say  that Jeffery he's a great singer he's  not on Blake's team Blake Shelton is  team Gwen all the way the voice coach is  putting his support behind his ladylove  he's also rallying to keep her on the  show for good are we any are we any  closer to adding a fifth chair  we'll just address that we loved when we  love all of our coaches and as a  producer is she coming back for Season  eleven right here as a yes an authority  on the subject please no but as an  executive producer Carson me our chairs  we're like iron chef's around here once  you've been in the kitchen you're always  welcome back in the kitchen any time you  want any time I'll see you next season  win